when you find a lost animal you often
make calls put up flyers in hopes that
the owner is close by yeah but for one
family in North Las Vegas they realize
the cat they found was a long way from
home
[Music]
they say cats have nine lives and who
knows how many Raven the cat has used up
it looks like she was in an engine when
somebody started it and her ear may have
been burned Elizabeth McGloin found
Raven in her neighborhood close to the
215 and Losi earlier this month come
here baby just for a second just knowing
somebody out there could be missing
their Kitty McGloin took Raven to get
her microchip scanned and found where
her owner lived I was like okay how the
heck did the cat get here Raven's
microchip showed she wasn't just a few
minutes away from home Raven was from
Alabama somehow she made the nearly 2
000 mile trip all the way to Las Vegas
but the question is how do we get raven
back home she's scared and she wants to
go home I just don't have the funds to
get her there over in Birmingham Alabama
Raven's owner Tracy cost got a call
she's been desperately waiting for I
can't believe she is alive I thought I
was never going to find her again cost
says raven got out December of 2021. we
searched and searched and could not find
her and to lose a cat she has had since
it was just a few days old was gut
wrenching I cried for days and I went
out every day searching for her there
was no doubt that this was her Raven
a cat that's been on the road all alone
for the last year and a half if she
could talk she would definitely have a
story to tell but for now Raven needs to
get home if anybody could help me get
her back to me I would so appreciate it
she's my baby
so how did Raven make it so far from
home the owners say they live close to a
truck stop so there could be a
possibility of her hitching a ride so if
you know of any organizations that can
help with funds to get raven back to
Alabama please reach out on our contact
us page on 8newsnow.com